يا غزه واحنا معاكم يا غزه واحنا معاكم يا
غزه واحنا معاكم يا غزه واحنا معاكم انتم
لستم وحدكم انتم لستم وحدكم يا غزا واحنا
معكم يا غزا واحنا معاكم انتم لستم وحدكم
يا غزاه يا فلسطين يا غزاه يا فلسطين معكم
كلنا اليمنيين مع اليمنيين الله اكبر
الموت لامريكا الموت لاسرائيل
الخروج الجماهيري اليوم هو ياتي نصره
لاخواننا في فلسطين وتضامنا مع اخواننا من
ابناء غزه الجريحه وانتصارا لمظلوم تهم
ومواجهه للطغيان الذي يفرض عليهم والحصار
المطبق عليهم اليوم شعبنا اليمني يقول
للعالم بان هذا الشعب هو مستمر في تضامنه
في نصرته مباركا لكل العمليات التي
يتخذها تتخذها الق القوات المسلحه اليمنيه
في البحر الاحمر باستهداف السفن
الاسرائيليه والامريكيه والبريطانيه
ونستطيع القول بانه اذا توقف العدوان ورفع
الحصار عن غزه فاننا سنرفع ايدينا عن
استهداف هذه السفن رع الطغيان مع الشر
امريكا الشيطان الاكبر من للبحر الاحمر
عسكر امريكا الشيطان الاكبر امريكا
الشيطان الاكبر من في هذا العالم اكبر
امريكا الشيطان الاكبر
[موسيقى]
مع غزه
ملتزمون الله
اكبر لبيك ياص
[تصفيق]
لبيك